las recomendaciones no bastaron horas
antes de que entrara en vigencia el
nuevo confinamiento decretado por las
autoridades británicas ante el aumento
de los contagios por kobe 19 y la
detección de una nueva cepa del virus
las calles de londres lucieron repletas
decenas de británicos atiborraron los
principales centros comerciales y
tiendas de regalos para abastecerse
antes del cierre que rige para más de 16
millones de habitantes y que fue
decretado por el primer ministro boris
johnson
no podemos continuar con la navidad como
estaba planeado en inglaterra quienes
viven en áreas de nivel 4 no deben
mezclarse con nadie fuera de su propio
hogar en navidad
las mismas escenas se repitieron en
rusia- mientras que la nación continúa
luchando contra el aumento sostenido de
los casos a través de medidas como la
cancelación de las ferias y
celebraciones públicas decembrinas en
moscú grandes masas de compradores se
movilizaron en los comercios durante la
noche del sábado con su mismo hermanos y
hermanas el consumismo ha secuestrado la
navidad
con su mismo non è en la mancha tuya no
hay consumismo en el pesebre de belén
lo que hay es realidad pobreza y amor
poder está el amor la capital italiana
fueron muchos los que sin
distanciamiento social y algunos en
mascarillas de protección recorrieron
tiendas que cerrarán en roma desde el 23
de diciembre por ser consideradas no
esenciales todos inmersos en una suerte
de frenesí navideño que por horas parece
haberlos hecho olvidar el riesgo de
continuar en medio de una pandemia